I truly think that having a kid is one
of the most narcissistic things a person
could do I believe that I do believe
that I don't think it's a conscious
decision that people have I think it's
this subconscious thing that's in the
back of everyone's head which is this
idea of you know I'm like me I think
there should be more of me in the world
that was David Prosser that clip from
his brand new stand-up special oh come
on the actor and comedian has been a
fixture in TV and film for more than 25
years and along with longtime
collaborator Bob Odenkirk he's half the
duo behind HBO's mr. show which earned
him three Emmy nominations Jamie wax sat
down with cross to talk about his comedy
career including it's painful origins
Jamie good morning good morning Anthony
that's right I spoke with David Cross at
one of his favorite performing venues
here in New York he talked about growing
up in Atlanta and why comedy is so
important to him and he opened up about
something he rarely if ever has spoken
about it seems no matter where David
Cross goes excuse me do these
effectively hide my thunder people
recognize him from somewhere why would
you say that where exactly that
somewhere is depends on the person what
do people recognize you for mostly when
they see you on the street it really
depends I don't have a hundred percent
success rate but I'd say I have about an
eighty to eighty-five percent success
rate at looking at them and knowing very
quickly this is how you know me really
you can spot like an Arrested
Development person and yeah are you
crazy
these things are kind of all over the
map and far apart like so you know
chipmunks Alvin I you know is almost
always you either or sometimes parents
will go like I had to watch that a
hundred times thank you for being funny
and you're in luck because your uncle
Ian came through and mr. show is sort of
sprinkled amongst those things
hey buddy try it on
mr. show with Bob and David foot cross
on the national stage and also propelled
the career of his comedy partner Bob
Odenkirk
you're just jealous cuz I'm more of a
woman than you'll ever be like cross
Odenkirk has had tremendous success
individually with acclaim turns in
Breaking Bad and it's hit spin off
better call Saul It's Showtime folks
the solo triumphs haven't taken away
from the fact that Bob and David
remain uniquely connected you compared
the relationship between a comedy team
to a marriage yeah in the same way that
Naomi and I my wife and I it's always
kind of fresh it almost feels like the
first moment when we first met is
happening still and I think David and I
have the same thing he's funnier than me
and I am funny but he's funnier than me
whoever's funniest the to have each
created numerous memorable characters
together and on their own including what
might be the role crosses most
frequently identified with Tobias fünke
a of the revered TV comedy it's Arrested
Development I'm afraid I just blew
myself it's gotta be a better way to say
that those were the greatest days those
are so much fun and man we would just
crack each other up constantly and and
you know it was very very much like a
family through all the acting writing
and directing opportunities Cross stayed
connected to the creative outlet that
first got him noticed highly original
stand-up canting minimum wage to people
and there when they're you know ask any
question but I mean so how's going what
are you making now
minimum wage yeah lowest amount legally
possible
it's an outlet that began for cross when
he was searching for a voice as a kid in
an Atlanta suburb take me back to you in
Georgia your teenage kid really do you
want to go there I do I would walk
through Atlanta with you right now I
love Atlanta just the childhood was not
great right cross his father abandoned
the family when he was just a teenager
something that still impacts him as he
races his daughter how do you break that
pattern and become a good father I know
what I and my sisters went through my
mom I'll be real honest with you it
worried me but what if there's that
thing in me what if it's a gene what if
it's the thing that let my dad just
abandon us and what if it's there's a
thing where you have three kids I've
always imagined this I wanted to put it
put a scene in something where my dad
just sort of rationalized it and went
you know what I honestly did think I
wanted to have kids and be married but
now I know I don't I don't
so anyway I'm going to take off and and
I'm what if there's that ability to
rationalize that thought that what if I
have that that thing in me and it would
really scared me
and I try not to let on at all
I don't even think of I don't know if
that I've talked about it's up here but
and I still don't know if you know she's
she's gonna be six or seven I'm gonna be
like yeah even so Cross acknowledges
there were gifts he received from his
father my dad coincidentally opened the
doors that were commie he turned me onto
Abbott and Costello and the Marx
Brothers and he loved comedy and kind of
got me into that stuff but you know it
is a fascinating thing to be a part of
now cross is passing on that love of
comedy to his daughter taking her on
tour around the world I'm really looking
forward to that
that big shift
you know that happens a big change where
you finally start to love them and
that's well hurry up with that part
please when isn't gonna be worth it in
any way shape or form and as a member of
crosses chosen family Bob Odenkirk says
the relationship will last into the
future
can you ever foresee a time in your life
when you don't perform with David Cross
no I know when we're dead we'll
hopefully be Holograms doing an act
together somewhere the Smithsonian
comedy wing alternative Hall and cross
is approaching what's next with the same
lack of planning that's gotten him this
far if everything else goes wrong I can
always do stand-up
why is stand-up so important to you it's
important to me because especially as I
do other all these other kind of
satellite things that aren't that are
bits and pieces of me but aren't really
me that that's that's me I've got a
record for my daughter if anything
happens to me that's who your dad is
that's what your dad thought was
important his new comedy special oh come
on is available on iTunes Amazon and
other online platforms I mean you think
about it even his father leaving did
give him something the way he as a
father now it's such an interesting
dilemma for in the father-son
relationship is the good and the bad but
woody what do you take what do you hold
on to very much so so happy you shared
well if that runs through I think every
parent's mind it does but I do think
that experience either makes you a very
bad parent or a very good yeah